Oh.
Oh gosh, I'm so embarrassed.
My voice sounds so bad.
I sound like a rugrat.
For real.
Welcome back.
Master, ma'am.
I'm even more embarrassed because this might be some people's first time hearing me.
And I sound like a rugrat.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, happy new year.
Oh my gosh, this is my first stream of the new year.
Happy 2025.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
For those who don't know, I just got back from Nihon.
I just got back from Japan.
And in Japan, I got sick.
And you're probably just like, how does a ghost get sick in Japan?
Well, I always say that being a ghost is overrated.
Because, because it's just like being human with a little less gravity.
A little less gravity involved.
But yeah, Year of the Snake, and my first stream back is Toho!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
Wow, I can't believe my first stream back is a sponsored stream.
But this is a really exciting sponsored stream, I think.
Because I'm gonna be in the game!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, it's Kanako's year.
Oh, let me introduce myself for maybe people who don't know me.
My name is Mint Frantom.
Some people are probably just like, why is TohoLossword collabing with this random VTuber?
Well, I kind of like Toho a little bit.
I'm new here, but you're really neat and I like you.
Thanks!
Screen person, yeah.
It's been a long journey for me with Toho.
So I... how long have I been in Toho for?
A long time!
I can... hold on, I have to look this up.
Oh gosh, I might be aging myself real bad.
So...
I can remember when UFO was released.
Like, I remember...
When UFO...
That's how long...
Wow, no way.
No way.
That's way too long.
You don't have to admit that.
I'm trying to...
It's my credibility points.
I also aged with this.
Not so long.
Credibility earned.
Yippee!
Yeah, so...
How's the granny voice?
It's not a granny voice.
I prefer Rugrat voice.
But...
I started with Toho, you know, kind of like maybe most people.
Where it's like I would listen to like the IOSYS covers and everything.
And then I'd be like, these girls are so cute!
I want to know more!
And...
You know, everybody has listened to Overdrive and Murase Stole the Precious Thing and everything.
So I started with those.
I remember very specifically, like...
Overdrive, like, changed my brain chemistry.
So I was like, wow.
My first was Bad Apple.
I'm sure that's a lot of people's first.
Now Bad Apple is like a meme, right?
As for games...
Oh gosh.
I can confidently say I've beat...
Like a handful of them.
Could I do that nowadays?
Probably not.
But...
You know...
I did then.
I earned my badge back in the day.
Mine was Nekomiko Reimu.
Nekomiko Reimu, I love you.
Nekomiko Reimu, what are you doing?
But one thing amazing about Touhou Last Word is they also have so much great music, right?
Touhou is not even just the games, but it's the music, it's the community, it's everything that...
Touhou is such like a...
Oh my gosh.
It's such a...
How do you say?
Like its own culture, I would say.
Its influence has been seen everywhere.
And so honestly, I'm just so honored to be sponsored by Touhou Last Word.
I'm so, so honored because I truly believe that my true otaku journey started when I got into Touhou.
Because when I got into Touhou, it was like...
Then I also got more into like Nico Nico Douga and kind of the subsets of the otaku...
Like...
Otaku...
Culture.
So, you know, it's really...
It's really a series that is so precious to my heart.
For me...
Gateway Drug.
The Ronald McDonald mess.
But for Touhou Last Word...
Actually, well, I guess there might be some people that are like, I don't really know what Touhou is.
You told us you got into Touhou via Danboru.
Well, that too.
Well, that's how I like...
Okay.
Yes, I mean, I found like the characters on there.
That's how I like was like, oh my gosh, these girls are so cute.
I was kind of like, what is this?
You have the music, you have the characters, what?
Everything combined.
Do you have any Fumos?
Yeah, well, okay.
Oh my gosh, I have Bimbo Ghost Fumo.
I have Bimbo Ghost Fumo.
She is...
She is on my...
She is on my shelf.
Currently.
As for...
I used to have a Rei Mufumo.
I don't know where it is anymore though.
I don't know, maybe she got lost.
I used to have one.
It left.
She is off fighting...
She is off saving the weather.
Or something.
Something weird.
The weather is acting up again in Gensokyo.
She had to...
She is off to her home planet.
For those who don't really know what Touhou is.
Touhou is a collection of games.
And just all sorts of different kind of media.
Started as games.
Now there is like, you know.
It's kind of grown into...
All sorts of...
There is novels.
There is...
There is a limitless amount of doujinshi.
There is music.
There is everything.
The games are...
Started as like a bullet hell thing.
Game series.
Sorry.
I have sick brain.
So my...
So my thought process is a little...
A little off today.
So I apologize.
But...
Unlimited doujin works.
Yeah.
There is so much.
And...
It's just...
It's a whole culture of its own.
But I find that, you know.
As much as there is of Touhou.
It's...
I wouldn't say it's too difficult to get into.
Because...
You know.
You have the canon of the games and everything.
But then...
Like...
And then there is, of course.
Like I said.
The novels too.
Which I do have.
A signed...
Actually I have two signed ZUN things.
I have one of the soundtracks.
And then I have one of the novels.
From when I met ZUN before.
So...
Yes.
I have things.
But...
I wouldn't say it's so difficult.
Because the fanon has also created...
There are different aspects of the fanon.
So...
Honestly.
Getting into Touhou.
You can really just kind of...
Go in anywhere.
You can be like...
I wanna start with the music.
And if you only like the music.
If you're like...
I'm not really much of a gamer.
You can just listen to the music.
If you wanna play the games.
You can play the games.
You know, it's just...
Who is my most fave character in Touhou?
I must say that I am very...
I am very partial to...
I love her so much.
But...
I also love Patchouli.
I love Kogasa.
But also I have characters...
Okay.
Does anyone else have characters that they like?
And then characters that they love for their theme of?
You know what I mean?
Like for characters that I really love their theme song.
I love Patchouli for her character.
But I also love her theme.
And then I also love...
I love Byakuren for her theme song.
Kanako for her theme song.
Honestly, I love...
Boss theme songs so much.
They're so good.
But...
Locked Girl is a great theme.
Yeah!
Cool and Create has a...
Has a version of the song that I really, really like.
Rainy Girl.
So...
You know...
But I think Kogasa is just...
She's the cutest thing ever.
She's...
She's always trying to spook me.
And I love that about her.
And then Patchouli is just so cute.
And of course, Remilia is just the cutest ever.
Remilia.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I explained Touhou a little bit.
Touhou lost word.
Since that's what we're all here for today.
It's actually...
So it's like a licensed RPG.
Featuring the characters of Touhou Project.
So it isn't like, you know...
It's a Touhou...
It's like an official Touhou game.
And you know, you get all the characters.
You get to see them.
What's so fun is you get to see them in different outfits.
And you know, they experience all sorts of different kind of...
You know...
Kooky situations as things happen in Gensokyo.
The Touhou lost word costumes are actually insane.
I don't know if anyone saw like the night designs and everything.
It's so...
They're so...
I'm like...
They're like...
If you want your character...
If you want your favorite character in an outfit...
It will probably appear in lost word.
They're so fun.
All the designs are so good.
Armor journal, yeah!
It's so...
Oh my gosh, it's so cool.
And I remember they had...
Oh my gosh.
Like, there's also all colors of the characters and everything.
It's so...
There's so much in there.
We'll get into the game in just a minute.
Yeah, so you...
You know, you collect your characters.
You got your...
You got your girls.
You got your friends.
Your friends in Gensokyo.
And then you can collect items to enhance your units.
For when you head into battle, baby.
So, yeah.
Before I open up the game though...
Do you guys want to hear a preview?
I mean, it was already posted.
The preview of my...
Of my cover song for the game.
But do you want to hear it again?
Do you want to hear it before it's released?
Just the...
Just the preview.
Okay.
Preview.
This is...
And then you'll hear what I actually sound like if this is your first time hearing me.
Instead of a squeaky rugrat.
You'll hear my actual voice.
Okey dokey.
Preview.
Start!
It's actually quite embarrassing listening.
It's actually quite embarrassing.
Listening to...
Listening to myself.
No, I want the full thing.
Well, the full thing will be...
Premiering...
In...
40 minutes, actually!
Hold on.
Watch...
We'll watch the premiere together.
But let me post a link real quick.
Watch the premiere...
Here.
And let me pin this.
Pin, pin, pin.
40 minutes!
So, a lot of people are just like, Oh my gosh.
For those who don't know, I'm kind of obsessed.
I'm very kind of brain-rotted with a certain series of games that involves the Medalist of Gears.
And of course, my name is Mint Phantom.
So I was like, when the Lost Word team came to me, they were like, we want to collab with you on a song.
And they asked if I would like...
You know, they were like, you can choose the song that you want to sing from the songs that we have released.
And I was like, not gonna lie, I was bouncing between a couple because there were some other songs that I really, really liked.
But in the end, I was like, I have to do Phantom Pain.
It's literally made for me, but I also was kind of, you know, I was nervous about it because I'm not so attached to Kasen as a character so much.
So I was nervous about that.
But also, I love the original version so, so much because I'm a really, really big fan of the singer who does the original, Kotoko.
I really love Kotoko-san.
I've been a huge fan of hers for as long as I've loved Touhou, probably.
So, I was like, I don't know if I can do this version justice, but hopefully you guys like my version too.
And the song itself is like, oh my gosh, it was so much fun to sing.
It was so actually kind of difficult because it was very fast.
And it took me about like four hours just to record.
Just to record the one song took me about four hours.
And I ended up recording the whole thing and then I was listening back to it and I was like, no, I think I need to...
I think I need to...
I need to redo all the choruses because I didn't feel like they were...
they had enough oomph to them.
So I was just like, okay, back into the recording booth I go.
So I...
Phantom Pain is my favorite song in Lost Word.
Yeah!
Let's go!
I do want to show a bit of the songs that I wanted to sing today.
I was originally going to do a karaoke, but obviously, as you can hear,
that didn't end up working out so well.
But I want to show off some of the songs I was going to sing if that's okay because Lost Word has some amazing...
Oh my gosh, some amazing collabs and songs and everything.
And it's just...
Oh gosh!
They're so...
They have collabed with too many artists that I love.
Will we get a Touhou karaoke at some point in the future?
That's a great question!
Because they said that just because I couldn't sing it today, I can sing these songs in the future.
So...
I can sing them in the future.
In future karaoke.
So even if you don't hear them, me singing them today, you might hear them one day.
Let me pull it up and then I'll open up the game because I want to get my song in the game, you guys!
I want to get my song in the game.
Well, I say my song, my cover song.
One moment...
Let me put this down here.
Here.
Okay.
So the first song was one of the songs I actually considered doing as the cover song because because I really love this artist.
And it's a collaboration between, of course, legendary Touhou artist AYOSES and the queen of Akihabara herself, Momoi Haruko!
And so I was like, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, this is made for me.
So one second, I think...
Oh God, hold on.
It might be kind of loud for a second.
One second.
Oh gosh.
AYOSES, Momoi Haruko!
And of course, it's Patchouli!
I was like, all three of these things make me want to sing it.
Momoi Haruko's voice is just...
Oh my gosh, it feels like...
It feels like such, like an old school cover.
Like I could see this on Nico Nico Douga back in the day.
Bring back Tei!
Tei!
Let
me get my desk too so you guys can see.
It's such a cute song.
Haruko's voice is so perfect.
I love it.
I was like, I don't think I can do this song justice either.
That's my girl!
The art is so pretty.
So cute.
I'll try and sing it in the future.
Ah, I'm so obsessed with this song.
I'm so obsessed.
I've sung Haruko's songs in karaoke before.
Well, I guess only once.
But she's like, legendary queen of Akihabara.
I'm so obsessed with this song.
Oh no, more than one.
There are quite a number of characters in Touhou, huh?
So cute!
So, so cute!
I love that one so much.
Oh my gosh.
And then, earlier I mentioned, I mentioned Byakuren, right?
I really...
This is the right one, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the right one.
I mentioned really loving Byakuren's theme, so I also considered doing this one.
Oh, and before I continue too, for the music videos, for these songs, what's really cool is that the music video characters each have their own story in the game that takes place in their own world.
It's in the game, it's in a Touhou Lost Word called, in a part called Ruins of Memory.
So, you know, once you clear the story, most of the time clearing it will provide the player, you, with the character for that story.
So if you're just like, oh, I play this, and then you can get to that character once you, you know, so if you like the song, you can also...
Yeah, yeah, you, the player!
You, the player, you're the player.
So I mentioned liking Byakuren's theme earlier, so I also considered doing this one for the cover too, but I also really just wanted to sing it in the karaoke.
I'm so sorry my voice is like this today, I'm so sorry.
But we can at least listen to the beautiful original too.
It's so pretty.
The art is so pretty.
Holy again, that's me.
I'm becoming an angel.
So pretty!
So pretty.
And you can listen to all these covers on their YouTube channel as well.
The Lost Word YouTube channel.
They have a whole playlist of all of them.
English.
Ikinari Eigo.
It's so pretty.
I've listened to this one so much.
Oh my god, it's so good.
Oh, it's so good.
And the
visuals!
Sorry, I'm freaking out.
It's so pretty, oh my gosh.
I can't.
She looks so awesome.
I love it.
I love Byakuren so much.
Oh my god.
Me too, I'm on the bike.
Sorry, I stopped talking.
I was just vibing so much.
Sorry.
I just love this song so much.
We're behind them.
How did I hold that note for so long though?
Oh.
It's just so beautiful, I can't.
This one feels like a clown.
Yeah!
I feel like...
This one deserves more recognition.
It's just so pretty.
Byakuren's so cute.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
It's so...
It's just so...
Actually...
I used to cosplay Touhou quite a bit actually.
A long time ago.
I mean, I've been in Touhou for so long.
But...
I don't think she was my first cosplay.
I can't remember who I cosplayed first.
But...
I cosplayed Nui.
At one point.
I used to make them all myself.
I cosplayed Nui.
I cosplayed Mistia.
I cosplayed Chen.
I cosplayed...
Who else?
Uh...
I can't remember.
It's been so long.
Mistia?
Nui?
Chen?
I actually never did familiar.
Okay guys, I can't...
This is like so silly maybe.
But I usually don't cosplay characters that I...
Love like my favorite characters.
Because I don't think I can pull it off.
I'm like...
If I cosplayed Remilia, I would do her such disservice.
She is too cute for me to cosplay.
I cosplayed Momiji.
I cosplayed Aya.
I cosplayed Shameimaru.
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've done quite a few cosplays actually.
Oh, I also...
Thank you guys for all the superchats and everything.
Because I got so many things to go through today.
We only have 20 minutes left before the premiere of the cover.
I'm not reading right now, but...
Thank you everybody.
Thank you so much.
I really, really appreciate it.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, I've done...
I think that's all of them though.
Maybe.
I can't remember now.
Maybe that's all of them.
Of the Touhou cosplays.
But like I said, I used to do quite a bit of Touhou cosplay.
So...
Yeah.
Okay, I have one more song.
I think.
That I was going to sing.
That I can show.
Well, actually I think there was two.
But I'm just...
Maybe we can...
I won't do the whole thing.
For these two next songs.
So you can go look them.
You can go...
If you like it, you can go find it on...
On their channel.
The next one is called Toki no Kyoukai.
Oh, sorry.
The first one.
The first song.
The Momoi Haruko one was...
Precious...
Word.
Sorry.
Tee tee.
And so...
That was the first one.
And then the other one we just listened to was Holy again.
And then this one is Toki no Kyoukai.
And...
Toki no Kyoukai is...
Is...
Yuyuko.
Sorry, I was like...
Is Yuyuko's theme.
So I was also just like...
Maybe I should cover this one.
Because, you know...
Ghost and ghost.
But also...
Because the singer of this song is another singer that I really, really love.
And really, really respect.
Ito Kanako-san.
Who...
If you recognize her name...
She did, you know, the...
The...
Opening for Steins Gate.
So let's listen to this one.
We won't do the full thing of this one though.
Sorry.
But this one is so...
It's so funky and fun.
I love it.
As you can see, like...
Mossberg collab with like...
In my opinion, the best of the best.
Because they're all my favorite artists.
To me, it's like a dream collaboration always.
And I would say that...
Even if I wasn't getting paid.
Gosh, it feels so...
It fuels my otaku soul.
I love the animation in this one too.
I wanna keep watching.
But I wouldn't have time for other stuff.
Okay.
I don't wanna pause it.
But yeah, so that...
Oh my gosh.
It's so great.
Oh my gosh, it's such a jam.
Need the link to that song.
Like I said, you can find all of these songs on the Toho Last Word YouTube channel.
Or get them in the game.
Or get them in the game, everybody.
And then you can listen to it as your home screen.
Yeah, did I mention that my cover song and all these songs...
You can set as your background music for the home screen of Toho Last Word.
So when you open up your game every time, you can hear these songs.
Or you could hear yours truly.
On the starting screen of the game.
Yeah, baby!
Now the last song is a bit selfish of a song, actually.
I was like, probably...
Maybe like...
Not very many people in the chat will know these artists.
But to me, it means the world to have these artists sing.
So the last song is a duet, actually.
Between...
Between a singer who was in an idol group that I recently went to Japan for.
Well, I literally got back yesterday.
But the idol group she was in disbanded this past weekend.
And her name is Naruse Ami!
And she helps with the Japanese livestreams for Lost Word.
And the other singer is Shioringo!
From another idol group that I like called Banja Naimon!
And so they did a collab together for this song.
And this song also feels like very...
Super like...
Old school Toho!
So, like...
Well, I mean...
You know what I mean.
Like the old Niconico Douga videos that you would watch.
It just feels so good.
So, let's listen.
That's my selfish...
It's my selfish request to listen to this one.
And
of course I...
That's like...
This is a dream made...
Dream collab for me!
Ah!
Their voices are so good!
They blend so well together.
Oh my god, their voices blend amazing.
Mountain of Faith has my favorite beats.
Like my favorite soundtrack.
But I think Imperishable Night is second for me.
I really love the music in Imperishable Night.
Ah, it's so hard!
I feel like I always switch.
I don't wanna stop it.
Okay, we'll listen to this one.
There's only a minute left, it's fine.
The best part is too is...
Lost Word has also collabed with another member of Denpakomi.
Nemoto Nagi.
So, I'm just like...
I'm like...
This game is like made for me.
And of course, I can't bring up a song that Itaso sings in without also bringing up the fact that I went to the Lost Word offices.
I posted on this on Twitter, but if you don't have Twitter...
I went to...
One second, wait.
I went...
There we go.
I went to the Lost Word office.
You can see me on the couch there, I'm sitting there.
And...
It was really cool to see where they do the live streams and everything.
I was like...
But...
The team there is just so nice.
I'm so grateful for this, look guys.
They gifted me...
A Shikishi.
Signed to me...
By Itaso!
Oh my gosh, I almost started crying when I got this.
I was like...
Oh gosh.
I'm so...
That's...
Signed to me.
She even wrote on the back.
She wrote like...
Let's keep loving Touhou Lost Word together.
I want a Shikishi signed by Minto.
Well...
Funny you should mention that, huh?
Because...
My head.
My big old head is blocking it.
There is a New Year's giveaway!
So if you log in 14 days into the game...
And reply to the campaign post on Twitter...
Or ex-formerly known as Twitter...
With the screenshot of you having logged in...
And hashtag LWMint.
Mint.
LWMint.
You have a chance to win my signature!
And...
Fumo!
Everybody's beloved Fumo Fumo.
Actually, that's why I went to the office.
Because I went and I went and signed all the Shikishi.
And I was like...
I felt very awkward.
Well, not because of them.
But because I was like...
This is so strange.
I've never signed Shikishi like this before.
It was kind of...
It was nervous for me.
You have until the 31st of this month, January.
You can...
You still have time.
You still have time to...
To...
Get into the game.
So...
Now...
We have about 8 minutes until the premiere.
I do want to...
I obviously have the game up.
I want to do some gacha and stuff too.
Let's maybe save the gacha for...
After...
The premiere.
But let's open up the game still.
Wait a second.
I got to get my...
I got to get my iPad.
Let's go gambling.
Dang it.
Actually, no.
Every character is...
Is precious.
Every friend...
Everyone is a friend, right?
Except when you're trying to get a specific friend.
Alright.
One moment.
Can you guys hear that?
You guys can hear that, right?
Let me know if you can hear the game.
Oh,
that's why.
Oh, you guys couldn't hear the music this whole time?
I'm so sorry.
I just realized that I had music playing, you guys.
And you couldn't hear it.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
You just heard the silence.
That's a little scuff.
I apologize for my scuff.
We heard the songs.
Okay, at least you heard the songs.
No, I had like a BGM going.
While I was just talking.
Okay, one thing that is my favorite part probably about Lost Word...
Is the sheer amount of stuff they give you.
So I haven't opened it up for today.
I opened it up for yesterday.
But...
Let's see how many notifications we got.
This is so...
It's always so funny.
And then of course we'll get...
First thing.
Yippee!
Sparer points.
Gimme gimme.
We're getting BGM.
But this is not my BGM.
Not my BGM.
Thank you, Flan.
More BGM!
More BGM.
Thank you, Koishi.
Thank you, Kene.
More stuff?
What's next?
Oh my god, I love Nazrin.
She is so cute.
Nazrin is precious.
More stuff?
What's next?
Yeah!
Yeah, more stuff!
More...
Yeah!
Oh my god, wait.
There's Kasen.
Bonus simulator.
For real, there is so much free stuff.
And this is...
The best part is that this is like...
This is like all the time.
More stuff!
That's me!
Oh my god!
Mom!
Mom, I'm in the game!
That's it!
Phantom Pain!
Everybody wins!
You guys, look.
You can win your own yukkuri cushion.
Look, look, look, look.
Look how cute they are.
They are so proud.
I really like the Marisa one because she looks so...
Actually, no, I like them both.
Oh,
time to roll.
Okay guys, let's see.
The only man in Gensokyo.
100!
Oh, I don't think I'm gonna get it.
Tomorrow.
Alright.
That's me!
You guys should all...
Tap to watch, of course.
Look!
We have Remilia in the game!
And then...
Of course, we have her theme.
Of course, we have her theme as my home screen.
Because we have made Remilia.
One minute!
I'm so
proud!
Okay, hold on.
I'm also jamming to this.
Okay, see you.
Bye bye for a second, Ojoisama.
Okay, hold on.
Let me pull up the premiere.
I have the YouTube.
And then I have the link, of course.
I'm so nervous!
Oh my gosh, I'm so nervous!
I'm nervous.
Loud!
Oh my gosh, loud.
YouTube, why do you do the way that you do?
Why are you the way that you are?
Oh wait, hold on.
Sorry, I'm setting up the video.
So we can watch it.
Okay, that should be good.
That should be good.
I'm nervous.
I'm nervous!
The background music is so loud.
I know, I even turned it down.
I'll turn it down a little bit more.
I'm nervous!
Oh gosh, I hope you guys like it.
45 seconds.
I'll turn it up, don't worry, once it starts.
But for now, we'll have it not so loud.
I'm nervous.
25.
I might shut up though.
So you guys can just listen to it.
Oh god,
here we go!
Here we go!
Just pretend I'm singing it right now.
That's me!
Oh, sweet dreams.
Ah, here we go!
Ah, the outfits.
I'm nervous.
That's so cute!
So pretty!
I'm
nervous.
No!
I'm nervous.
Wow, Phantom Pain!
Ah, that's me!
That's me!
That's
me!
Oh gosh.
Embarrassed.
So embarrassed.
Yay!
It's such an awesome song.
I'm so honored to have been able to sing it.
Yay!
I hope you guys liked it.
And please repeat it over and over and over again.
Or, also, get it in the game!
Let's go back to the game now.
Oh, it's a Phantom Pain.
Well, hide it in the rain.
Well, Phantom Pain.
Of course I sound like, so stinky right now, but...
Yay!
Hello, clown piece.
This is the original!
I love Kotoko so much.
Alrighty!
So, of course, we have to pull, right?
They did provide this...
They did provide this account for me.
Don't get too jealous if I pull something that you really wanted.
But I want to see what friends we have too.
Okay, so this is who we're starting with, right?
This is who we're starting with.
I'm so upset.
Oh gosh, look at her in the background and everything.
Look how cute she is.
She's so noble.
She's so cute.
Remilia-sama!
Okay.
I'm kind of obsessed with these song choices.
Alright.
So, as you can see, for the New Years...
We have...
Blue Reimu!
And...
Ta-da!
Red Marisa!
Oh my gosh, aren't they so...
Oh my God, I can't...
I kind of love characters that have, like...
You know how, like, on New Years they have...
They, like, draw on their faces and everything.
I...
I'm so cute.
Claim your mail!
I probably should wear this over there.
There it is!
Ta-da!
Koishi!
Let it rain.
Oh my gosh.
More friends!
More?
Oh my gosh.
I'm so rich.
Koishi.
For the...
The New Years...
I really want to get...
I really want to try and get both of them.
So...
There's, like, a little bit of a backstory behind why there's, like, Blue Reimu and Blue Marisa.
But...
Essentially...
Like...
It's, like, different universe...
Reimu and Marisa.
And, like...
Yukari.
She, like, sends them off...
To explore other worlds and stuff.
So...
It's kind of cute.
Good luck on your pulls.
07.
07 for our...
I mean, look at how much...
I think I have...
I think I have enough to pull them.
I'm not gonna lie.
Another thing that I really love about Lost Word is...
And...
They put so much care into...
Into, like...
You know...
Officially...
The characters don't have, like, official VAs, right?
Official Seiyuu.
And...
There's so much fanon involved in Touhou.
That a lot of people kind of create their own headcanons for characters and...
Stories and just kind of things like that.
So that...
In Lost Word...
For each character...
Let me see, hold on, let me go back before we do the gacha.
Let's just do Chirno.
Hold on, I have to...
It's so cute.
Look at all this.
For each character...
You can choose a different voice actress.
Up to three!
Voice actresses, they have...
That, like...
If you're just like...
This version doesn't really suit the kind of...
Version in my head that I had for...
Chirno.
You can switch it!
Hold on.
Does anyone remember where it's at?
Sorry, my brain is so...
And look at all the outfits they have too!
Wait, this is literally me?
It's a chocolate maid?
Hello?
It's literally me!
But yeah, so it's just like...
They really do put a lot of care into...
Making sure everybody has their...
Best Touhou experience!
Depending on how they enjoy Touhou, right?
Look at the feet!
Yeah!
I'm so obsessed with this song, sorry.
Okay.
Alright.
For real!
The book?
Oh, thank you.
Thanks, Mod.
Sorry, it's been a minute since I've played Touhou Last Word.
And I'm also sick, so I can't remember anything right now.
Ah, here we go!
Yeah, yeah.
Isn't it so awesome?
They're just a little bit different.
I like this one.
So you can do that?
Let's hear Remilia-sama.
I really like that one.
This one's a little bit more like...
A little more...
Refined.
Sounds a little older.
And this is a good mix of the two.
I think.
This one is like a mix between Ojoou and...
But I like her.
I like her being bratty.
Look at all these costumes!
Oh my god.
No!
I cried.
Bloody nurse!
Oh my gosh.
Triggered.
So cute.
So good.
So, I think that's just such a really cool detail.
That like...
You don't really think about for...
For games, you know?
Like...
I mean, usually for like a game...
It's gonna be...
Either like...
If it's like of an already existing property...
It's gonna be...
Like this original seiyuu.
Is this live or recording?
This is live, baby!
And for like original series...
That like become gacha games or whatever...
You know, the characters are gonna have their own...
You know...
Pre-assigned seiyuu.
But with this, like Touhou is in...
It's own kind of middle grade ground.
So it's fun.
This is recorded live.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess we'll go for Rainbow Blue first, right?
Let's go for Rainbow Blue.
Okay.
Let's use my cubes.
I have many of them.
I think first pull.
I think first try.
First try, baby.
First try!
I'm not looking, I'm not looking, I'm not looking.
There's our friend!
It's just a bunch of flowers.
Okay, this is for Yuka.
No!
Everybody, don't forget to donate to your local shrine maiden, okay?
Don't forget to donate to your local shrine maiden.
No!
The
art in this game is so cute.
Oh my gosh.
This is sad.
This is very New Year's, huh?
Okay, this seems very New Year's.
Makes me want some oranges.
Nice rock.
That's a rock fact.
Okay, got the sunflowers again.
Oh gosh, what's her name again?
Yes,
thank you.
I wanted to cosplay her too.
She's so cute.
Ah!
But this is not...
This is not Blue-Eyed Moon.
Wrong blue.
One more!
Okay.
The sun is friend guaranteed.
So we know we're gonna get a friend.
But...
There she is.
That's Raymoon.
I can feel it.
In my ectoplasm.
I can feel it in my ectoplasm!
Oh my gosh.
This art is so cute!
That's so cute.
Bug.
Oh my god, this art is the cutest!
Yeah, a certain night bug perhaps.
A certain wriggly night bug.
Ojo-sama!
Ruin cleaning stuff, Ojo-sama!
Oh my god, so cute.
Wait, who's the artist for this?
I love all the different uses of artists too, you know?
The name.
Sorry.
I'm professional.
I'm professional today.
I'm seiso.
I'm seiso, I'm seiso.
Miracle night.
Certain Onis drink from that.
Usually I'd be like...
This was faded.
Did you see how many...
Did you see how many Remilia cards we pulled?
This was like faded.
Maybe we have to...
Hold on.
Maybe I have to switch.
Let's switch to my cover.
I mean, this cover is great and all.
Whoever sang it sounds great.
But...
But let's switch to my cover.
That just premiered.
What?
Wait, how do I go to it again?
Is it through here?
I forgot again.
Sorry guys.
I'm such a bad streamer.
Where was it again?
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Ah!
There is a Discord too!
You can see it.
There's a Discord if you're interested.
Because the devs are pretty...
They're...
They're pretty active.
Like talking and everything.
And they'll be like...
Face icon.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Awesome.
My cover.
Let's see though.
You know what?
Let's get these two.
Because they're the best.
Wait, no, no, no.
Switch though, switch.
Switch, switch, switch, switch.
Hold on, let's go to...
Go page.
Go back.
Wait, go page?
Go page!
Go back.
No!
Go page!
Go back.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
Okay, now we'll have good luck.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
That's really weird.
Oh my god, that's me.
That's me saying a lot.
Amelia refusing to leave.
Yeah, but...
I don't want her to go.
Did you guys have a good New Year's?
I swear that's me singing.
Even though I sound like this right now.
That's me singing, I promise.
Oh, sweet dreams.
See, I told you!
Good luck!
Good luck if you put on my song!
Why does it hurt?
Is this...
Lily White?
One of the fairies.
This art is so cute.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
It's spring!
Even when it's not spring.
According to Lily.
It's a really guard card?
Oh, really?
Let's go.
Emerging power.
You guys like?
We're at the Hakurei Shrine.
Oh, we got this card again.
Okay.
Bloom!
Show.
Toramaru.
Yeah, we're not going to press the skip button because we like the anticipation.
That was the Moriya Shrine.
No!
I mean here!
Here!
We're at the Hakurei Shrine!
What are you talking about?
My background.
Oh, Sanae!
Oh my gosh.
Look how cute she is.
I need to know the artist for all of these.
For...
For small reasons.
Oh my god!
Whoa, the thigh.
You guys see that squish?
PENTA PAIN!
Bimbo...
Bimbo Miko.
Hayate is fun.
She's so cute.
How is this...
How is this happening?
This is just fate!
Oh my god!
With the Remilia theme, we got Remilia.
And then with the Kaisen theme, we got Kaisen!
How?
PENTA PAIN!
No, this is Touhou!
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Touhou lost word.
Keep going.
We'll get Bloomer.
PENTA PAIN!
Maybe the PENTA PAIN is not getting the character you want.
Truly.
And we know it's gonna...
Oh, sorry.
Two?
Two friends?
Why are we still here?
Just...
Three friends!
It's a triple baby!
Wait, who are the other two then?
Bloomer!
Oh my gosh, I love the little Suika.
The little baby Suika next to her is so cute.
Can you see her here?
Oops, I didn't mean to tap out of it.
Cute, cute, cute, cute, cute.
We were just talking about you, Rego.
Who's this?
Flan!
Go away, Twitter!
Flan-chan.
Okay, we got one more to go through though.
Okay, hold on, we'll just...
Skip through the cards that we've seen before.
Oh my gosh, clown pieces.
Using all her 2025 luck right now.
Don't say that!
Tiger and dragon.
So cool.
Here we go!
Oh, Aki!
Aki.
Twitter, go ahead.
Literally, yeah, you were so right.
Cute.
Very cute.
Oh,
she's crying.
Why is she crying?
Stop!
There we go.
Hold on.
So this is how you...
This is how you train them.
You use all your...
I don't...
I don't have anything.
But...
You use your items to make them stronger.
Or when you use them in battle.
In game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, of course, you know.
Limit break and everything.
All the...
All the stuff...
For, you know...
Gaming.
All the gaming gamings.
Oh, oh wait.
Oh, here we go.
Sorry, I feel like my throat is getting worse.
Ahem.
Hello Sumida.
Thank you.
Sorry.
It doesn't hurt if you're wondering.
It's just...
It just sounds like it hurts.
It just sounds bad.
What?
What is your headcanon rainbow sound?
Tired.
Haha.
I think this one so far.
No, I think this one.
I think I like this one.
Two and three are close.
Yeah.
It has a bit more...
Of a mature tone.
Got her in 40 pulls.
Let's go!
Yeah!
Nice.
Yeah, I think three.
Yeah, it feels very...
Yeah, a little tomboyish.
That's how I feel for her too, right?
A little tomboyish.
Like...
Alright.
So we got...
We got Bloom.
Now we gotta get Redisa.
Now we gotta get Redisa!
Let's see.
But look at all these other...
I should also, of course, highlight the other...
Gacha that are happening.
And when I say the other gacha that are happening...
You guys.
You guys!
Getting a little yukkuri still.
There is an insane amount...
Of things.
I love this.
It's spring!
Even when it's not!
You got this.
Zanmu Limited.
And then...
A love all color Letty...
Letty.
Letty White Rock.
I don't know why I could not say her name.
Letty.
You got all these.
You got Goth Yomu!
In there.
So cute, so cute.
Class collection.
Oh my god, Yomu in the little...
In the little poncho is too cute.
I can't.
Look at all these.
Look at all these different outfits.
They are so fun.
Oh my god.
All color Flan kills me.
Look how cute she is.
I mean, she just looks like Remilia.
But look how cool Raisen is.
Yeah, there is so much here.
And of course...
Of course, because of Phantom Pain...
You can pull for...
Kassan!
Actually...
Maybe instead of...
Redessa, we pull for Kassan.
Let's play...
Let's try for Kassan.
We'll see how lucky we get.
We got her already, but I want her more.
Oh yeah, wait.
You're right.
I did pull Kassan.
I didn't just get her on the banner.
But it feels more special when you get her on the banner, right?
Oh, we got the Hakurei shrine.
This is bigger Kassan.
Oh my gosh, this looks so amazing.
Sorry, I appreciate art.
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Cute!
How many artists...
How many artists have worked in Lost World, I wonder?
I'm the strongest of the artists.
We have the other fairy.
Well, the other fairy of many.
Nameless greater fairy is so sad.
Let's try again.
More Kassan.
The other fairy is just disrespectful.
I apologize.
She's the nameless greater fairy.
It's kind of scary though.
It's cute, but kind of scary.
I love the Sakuya art.
Nico spotted.
I don't think I ever beat Ten Desires.
Now that I think about it.
I don't think I ever did.
Ten Desire let's play.
Maybe I should.
What was the gimmick in that game?
If you beat UFO, you get bragging rights.
Anyway, that game is tough.
You
can call me a gamer.
Back then, I could beat it.
Nowadays...
Nowadays, I don't think I could.
This art is so cute.
You can try.
I still think...
Subterranean animism is very difficult.
Oh, Kaguya!
First we get...
Eirin.
And now we get Kaguya.
Everything...
Everything I am.
Eirin and Kaguya.
Alright.
Cussing or bust.
Wait.
I know the issue.
It's because...
What's taking so long to load?
Why did it take so long?
Next is Mokou, right?
Right?
Wait.
We have to change it to my cover song.
Pass the wrong BGM.
Exactly.
That's why it took so long to load!
Also, this art is so cute.
I can't remember...
The little one's name.
The little character.
What's her name?
She has the big...
The big...
What's it called?
Needle.
What's her name?
Sukuna!
Shin Myomaru.
Thank you.
So many characters to remember.
So many to remember.
First...
Sorry, I keep muting the cough.
Usami!
Sumireko Usami.
Nashi nashi!
Sake!
Prism River.
Prism...
Prism River!
Wait, imagine if it was the other two.
For the other two people.
The two friends people.
That'd be crazy.
Imagine if we pulled all the Prism Rivers.
What kind of luck would that be?
That would be the most insane thing ever.
That makes me want some inari sushi.
Half phantom!
I'm full phantom, but...
Some people have compared me to Yomu in the past.
Mist!
Look how cute she is.
Oh my gosh, she's so cute.
You're both green and ghosts.
I'm too deep into the Toho rabbit hole.
I remember everyone's names in the greatest detail.
That's awesome.
Stay in the Toho hole.
I love this artist, Ixi!
I love Ixi.
Oh my god.
This Ixi is so happy!
I love Ixi art.
And Tan Cherno.
The biggest bonus.
This is an absolute win for me.
And our final friend.
I
did it!
She sounds so cool.
Success again!
Kai said, don't be, don't jump.
Amazing.
Amazing!
Wow.
Look at this pole.
This is insane.
BGM is not wrong after all.
I know, right?
But I want to listen to my cover.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's this one, right?
Switch.
That's why you're called Phantom.
I'm a ghost.
I'm a ghost maid.
Did I introduce myself at the beginning of the stream?
I did?
Sorry.
You can do it again now.
Welcome back.
Master.
Welcome.
I'm Miss Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid Vtuber.
I really love Touhou.
And I like Touhou music so much.
Welcome back.
I'm back.
It's actually me singing, I promise.
You kind of said, oh by the way, I'm Mint before.
I didn't really do a proper introduction.
I did talk about how I got into Touhou and stuff though.
And all the fun stuff.
There's honestly just so much that Lost Word has to offer.
If I were to get into all of it...
I'm already almost at the 2 hour mark.
You didn't say why you did sing Phantom Pain.
Yeah, no, I did say that though.
I did, I did, I did.
I did, I did, I did say that.
Yeah, I haven't even touched any of the actual game.
I haven't even touched any of the actual game.
I think I'm at my limit with my voice.
We were able to get Bloom and Kassen.
So I pray for everybody for your gacha luck.
If you are pulling for Kassen or Blue Rainbow or Red Marisa.
I got a notification for Touhou Lost Word.
I hope you enjoy your time in Gensokyo.
And be sure to check out, obviously the game, but also the Touhou Lost Word channel.
Because they have lots of other amazing songs and arrangements.
And I recommend them.
And then you can have them in the game.
I love this song so much, I can't get over it.
Kassen is just yapping.
She just doesn't shut up.
Congrats on the cover collab!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Yeah, there is a link below in the description.
You can also just get it from the game store as well.
The link just takes you to the website in the description.
But it shows you a little bit more about everything.
Look how cute that pink flan is.
The urge to pull.
The urge to pull for her.
Thanks for the sponsorship stream.
Thank you guys!
Log in, yeah, do your dailies.
Pull, pull, pull.
I wish you the best of luck in the new year with all your gacha.
And all of your gaming efforts.
Thank you so much again to Next Ninja.
For having me do the stream and having me do the cover song.
I'm really, really, really honored about it.
I think that's about it.
No.
Akidoki!
Atsumi-tan!
Go listen to the cover song!
Go, go, go, listen, listen, listen!
I'll see you guys later!
Sorry, my voice is so bad.
Oh wait, I forgot to do this too.
Kind of matches the vibes of this poem.
Maybe a little bit.
Bye!
Thank you!
Bye bye!
Atsumi-tan!
See you later!
Bye bye!